with any conflict most Americans just
why why are we doing whatever it is
we're doing and then understanding
whatever that reasoning is and what
would you say is the why we are over
there to to train advise and assist our
Afghan partners to get them into a more
stable position and specifically task
force southwest that's what we were
there to do so and maybe that's not
understandable and maybe the American
population doesn't understand the
importance of that but if you tie
everything back to the security of the
United States and and what our
priorities are here back here I think
you just have to look at the big picture
as a whole I mean what we do on the
small level affects everything that is
much larger so but I think overall
that's generally why the population
might not understand what the military
forces do in any location it's just
because they don't understand the why or
maybe the bigger picture behind it how
would you explain the why do you guys
get asked that why are we still in
Afghanistan do you hear that
what do you say well I mean I think a
lot of reason why the local populace or
even you know back here in the States
while a lot of people don't understand
it is I think it's more associated with
time - everybody's in there
now hey this is a you know I need to
know exactly why we're here and let's
move on to the next objective or move on
to the next issue that we have at hand
and they wanted to happen real quick and
I think a big part that we miss is that
you're you're providing security for a
country that is trying to look for
stability and they're trying to get
stability and with stability it's going
to take some time it's not something
that just happens overnight and then BAM
these guys aren't gonna be able to hold
it on their own so it's setting that
once again setting conditions so that
they can safely maintain you know civil
order amongst themselves and keep out
the threats that are constantly working
on their on their country and taking
away those freedoms that they are
currently trying to maintain what if we
weren't there and I think it goes I'll
go back to what I was saying before like
an insurgency is a pretty tough pretty
tough fight so it's it's difficult I
mean I can't you know predict the future
and see how how it would be oh but I
know they were having a hard time with
you know the normal governance and
providing those kind of services to the
people so yeah I mean that I guess no
reason to think it would turn around on
its own if we weren't there helping them
out